[Musique]
vous êtes sur france 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'afrique à la une ce soir le tchad un
an après la mort d'idriss deby et la
prise de pouvoir par un conseil
militaire de transition dirigé par son
fils mahammad idriss deby nous ferons le
point de la situation dans ce journal
un mini sommet de la communauté est
africaine anaérobie pour la paix et la
sécurité dans l'est de la république
démocratique du congo depuis plus de 25
ans cette zone est particulièrement
éprouvées par les guerres et des
violences meurtrières décryptage notre
correspondant à suivre dans cette
édition
et nous irons en côte d'ivoire où les
initiatives se multiplient pour
régulariser le travail informel qui
représente les trois quarts des
travailleurs du pays comme offrir un
statut audio soeur c'est ce qui vous
aide à vous garer
reportage à suivre
on ouvre ce journal par le tchad un an
après l annonce de la mort d'idriss deby
depuis cette date le pouvoir a été
repris par son fils mamad idriss déby à
la tête d'un conseil militaire de
transition l'anniversaire de la
disparition du maréchal est à peine
célébrée dans le pays le renverser cher
malgré les retards et les ratés marc
amat idriss déby reste confiant un nom
après la mort de son père le président
tchadien de la transition affirme que la
feuille de route annoncée en juillet
dernier sera respectée démentant les
pronostics présager la déchirure sociale
pour notre nation et les chaos
institutionnel pour notre pays la
transition continue résolument son
chemin depuis une année tant bien que
mal
après sa prise de pouvoir en avril 2021
le jeune général avait limogé le
gouvernement dissout le parlement et
abrogé la constitution
il avait justifié ses actes en
promettant des élections libres et
démocratiques dans un délai de 18 mois
et l'ouverture d'un dialogue national
inclusif mais un an plus tard ses
promesses semble loin d'être tenu plus
d'un mois après l'ouverture d'un prix
dialogue de paix avec une trentaine de
groupes armés à doigts aucun accord n'a
été trouvé dans ce contexte tendu la
tenue d'élections avant l'automne semble
de plus en plus incertaine alors que les
négociations piétinent la question du
départ de marc amat idriss déby prend de
l'ampleur le chef de la transition reste
pour l'instant évasif à ce sujet et
n'exclut pas une éventuelle candidature
à la future présidentielle
on passe à la tunisie où des dizaines de
réfugiés ont manifesté devant les locaux
du haut commissariat pour les réfugiés
pour réclamer leur évacuation dans un
pays tiers ce phénomène met en lumière
les difficultés du hr à s'occuper des
réfugiés de plus en plus nombreux en
tunisie le pays n'a pas de loi sur
l'asile les explications de notre
correspondante il y à blaise
nous trouvons actuellement devant le
haut commissariat des nations unies pour
les réfugiés à tunis c'est près de 150
personnes comme vous pouvez le voir
derrière moi qui vivent dans des
conditions très difficiles depuis une
semaine ces réfugiés sont en sit in et
il avait déjà commencé leur sit in dans
le sud de la tunisie à zarzis où ils
étaient hébergés par le hcr depuis le
mois de février ils ont été évacuées de
leurs logements d'urgence et n'ont pas
pu se reloger aujourd'hui demandent à
être évacués d'autres pays qui puisse
assurer leurs droits
[Musique]
on attend des investissements au café
pas son adresse ou des critiques dans
nos maisons
il y a tellement de gens ici moi j'ai
quatre enfants d'autres m'ont 6 on ne
peut rien faire on n'a pas de travail on
n'a pas de droit et le hcr met à la
porte sans rien et c'est pour cela que
nous venons ici protester
comme vous avez pu l'entendre dans les
témoignages de nombreuses femmes et des
enfants sont également présents dans ce
sit in une situation qui se complique et
surtout qui semble être à une impasse
puisque d'un côté le hcr a déclaré avoir
prévenu s'est réfugié dès leur
hébergement il y a quatre cinq mois que
la solution était temporaire et
qu'ensuite ils devraient être évacués et
se débrouiller en tunisie de l'autre les
réfugiés estime qu'il devrait avoir plus
de droit qu'il devrait pouvoir avoir
accès à une réinstallation notamment
dans des pays tiers une procédure qui
prend énormément de temps et qui se fait
dans des conditions très spécifiques
selon le hcr à titre d'exemple l'année
passée 76 personnes avaient bénéficié
d'une procédure de réinstallation depuis
la tunisie aujourd'hui ses 9500 réfugiés
qui sont inscrits au hcr dans le pays
un mini sommet de la communauté est
africaine s'est tenue ce jeudi à nairobi
en présence des présidents du kenya de
l'ouganda du burundi et de la république
démocratique du congo ainsi que du
ministre des affaires étrangères
ougandais qui se sont retrouvés pour
parler de la paix et de la sécurité dans
l'est du congo difficile pour autant de
savoir la teneur des discussions la
réunion s'étant tenue à huis clos à
nairobi bastien rôle
c'est la deuxième fois en deux semaines
que les chefs d'état d'afrique de l'est
se rend compte pour parler de la
situation sécuritaire dans l'est de la
rdc la première fois c'était lors de la
signature du traité d'adhésion à la
communauté d'afrique de l'est par la
république démocratique du congo les
chefs d'état qui se réunissent donc ici
à nairobi un sous l'égide du président
ou kenyatta pour évoquer la situation
notamment avec les attaques récentes du
m23 mais encore des milices adf et ce
alors que l'ouganda aide depuis la fin
de l'année dernière le congo puisque
plusieurs milliers d'hommes ougandais
sont présents au congo pour traquer les
adf pour tenter de les repousser le plus
loin possible de la frontière tenter de
reprendre leur camp et ce afin notamment
d' ouvrir des routes commerciales entre
les deux pays ce qui serait bénéfique
aussi bien à l'ère des séquelles ouganda
mais voilà malgré la présence des
militaires ougandais sur le territoire
congolais est bien la situation ne
s'améliore pas pour l'instant c'est
bintou keita qui le dit la chef de la
mission des nations unies au congo entre
le début du mois de janvier et la fin du
mois de mars 2022 il y a eu deux mille
trois cents civils tués dans les régions
du kivu il foule est donc extrêmement
important de trouver des solutions c'est
ce que les chefs d'état tentent de faire
ici anaérobie on ne sait pas combien de
fois ils se rencontreront à l'avenir
mais à terme et bien il devrait y avoir
un accord signé entre le ces chefs
d'état pour tenter de trouver une
solution à la situation dans l'est de la
république démocratique du congo
en côte d'ivoire les initiatives se
multiplient pour régulariser le travail
informel qui représentent 80% des
travailleurs direction le quartier du
plateau où la mairie a décidé d'offrir
un statut à ce qu'on appelle les
djosseurs ces vigiles de rue qui
vivaient de pourboire des automobilistes
auront désormais droit à une prime
mensuelle reportage de samuel bernard et
hanane ferjani
le plateau quartier d'affaires d'abidjan
est connu pour ces mamans vigile de
reiki carré surveille les voitures vous
irez le gagner leur vie grâce au
pourvoir aux automobilistes mais la
mairie a souhaité normaliser leur
travail chasuble numérotée casquette et
prime hebdomadaire à la clé
c'était pas bien désormais tu peux
vraiment parler en famille polygame on a
le culot qui lui fait cher la mairie du
plateau
ce qu'il a vécu cette pièce tard sony
une centaine d'entre eux ont été
sélectionnés par la mairie pour
rejoindre ce programme une goutte d'eau
dans l'univers des voituriers qui sont
encore nombreux à ne pas porter
l'uniforme pour le maire du plateau
cette initiative sera bénéfique sur le
long terme il rêve de l'étendre à
d'autres secteurs nous avons les namas
aujourd'hui demain on aura les vendeuse
de banane braisée voilà après deux
mornes aura des vendeuses du jus de
fruits mais on a organisé cela de plus
en plus d'initiatives individuelles
temps à leur façon de réguler le travail
informel pour cet expert ces changements
sont positifs à condition de ne pas
céder au clientélisme
donc c'est toujours bon de montrer qu'on
a radié en considération le le sort en
fait des petites gens maintenant qu'est
la sincérité en fait des démarches
qu'elles aient subi qu'on donne est ce
que c'est vraiment un programme qui est
réfléchi en plusieurs étapes parce que
simplement des opérations de
communication affectivement en côte
ivoire le secteur informel joue un rôle
important dans l'économie du pays il
contribué en 2010 est à plus du tiers du
produit intérieur brut
on passe au niger qui affronte cette
année l'une des plus dures crise
alimentaire des dernières décennies et
le pays voit des soutiens se multiplier
la banque africaine développement comme
d'autres acteurs débloque de nouvelles
aides pour empêcher le pays de
s'enfoncer dans la crise et tentent
d'agir sur plusieurs fronts décryptage
d'un rôle gérard de pigna
sécheresse et l'insécurité sont les
principaux facteurs de la crise
alimentaire mais aussi de la crise
agricole qui frappe le niger en 2022
l'état active tous les leviers à sa
disposition pour contrer les effets de
cette crise il y a quelques jours
plusieurs membres du gouvernement ont
conclu des accords de financement avec
la banque africaine de développement
pour un montant qui avoisinerait les 110
millions d'euros l'objectif principal de
ces accords et bien c'est le
désenclavement des zones frontalières
avec le nigeria voisin c'est à dire que
toutes ces zones situées juste à la
frontière juste au sud du niger
bénéficieront d'un programme
d'amélioration des routes mais aussi
l'amélioration des circuits commerciaux
pour que les marchandises principalement
alimentaires arrive en de plus brefs
délais à bon port l'état a également
voulu il y à quelques temps baisser les
taxes sur les produits alimentaires de
base pour laisser respirer les nigériens
si je prends l'exemple du mil c'est à
peu près 3 5% des réductions de taxes et
le gouvernement est allé jusqu'à
consenti une réduction de taxes des 35%
ou ce qui concerne le blé donc toutes
ces réductions de taxes ou en un sens
d'un fléchit un peu les prix à la
consommation
il faut agir si là qu'on peut la
composante alimentaire comme j'ai dit au
terme de son poids si les produits
alimentaires baissent savage ici les
prix à la consommation les prix à la
consommation aussi bessan donc fois
c'est moi le pouvoir d'achat des ménages
va être équilibré à moins qu'un c'est ça
par ailleurs la banque mondiale a
octroyé au niger 230 millions d'eu euro
pour faire face aux chocs climatiques
notamment les inondations qui
régulièrement ravage une partie des
cultures du pays pendant la saison des
pluies
à présent cet ultimatum en guinée issus
du front national pour la défense de la
constitution
c'était le fer de lance de la
contestation contre un troisième mandat
du président déchu alpha condé le fn
d'essai propose deux ans aux militaires
pour le retour des civils au pouvoir
cette organisation menacent de reprendre
les manifestations deux roues de rue car
elle soupçonne la junte de vouloir se
maintenir au pouvoir on écoute ses coûts
koundouno membres du fn décès
l'absence de dialogue et de concertation
inclusif et constructif entre monsieur
le cnrd et les forces vives de la nation
sur le contenu la durée et le commandant
de la tradition pour un retour à l'ordre
constitutionnel rapide plus de sept mois
après la prise de pouvoir par les armes
présente des risques du soulèvement
populaire certains dans leur conquête de
la prise des manifestations il est à
craindre que le recours à la violence
d'état soit après le rejet par la gêne
pour étouffer et museler les voix
dissonantes et s'éterniser au pouvoir à
maurice la hausse du coût de la vie
devient intenable les habitants ont
laissé éclater leur colère après la
hausse du gaz ménager de 30% et les
carburants de plus de 25 % ces dernières
semaines les habitants du quartier de
camp levieux sont descendus dans les
rues ce qui a provoqué une forte
mobilisation de la police de longues
heures de tension et deux arrestations
écoutez la réaction de rage elle narre
single professeur à l'université de
maurice au micro date de l'aea ali le
correspondant à pour lui
je fais président analyse au niveau de
l'afrique aucun pays africain n'a
augmenté ses prix comme on le fait
sauvagement à maurice donc vous imaginez
le prix de l'essence le prix du diesel a
augmenté d'une façon drastique allez au
supermarché vous allez voir comment les
prix comparé à d'autres pays africains
il y a aucune justification il faut que
immédiatement le gouvernement donne de
support ce qu'on appelle de income sopot
à des gens qui n'ont pas les moyens les
gens qui ont moins de quinze mille
roupies ils doivent avoir ce droit droit
à la nourriture droit à la santé
ces gens là doivent avoir ses moyens
avec le gouvernement
c'est ainsi que nous refermons ce jour
n'a de l'afrique merci à tous ceux qui
nous ont suivis de niamey anaérobie en
passant par ni amène à rester avec nous
car l'actualité continue sur france 24
[Musique]